hébergement d'urgence maraude avec
distribution de repas chauds remise de
colis alimentaires le centre d'études et
d'initiatives musulmane des yvelines
offre toute l'année aux familles les
plus démunies des vivres avec le
confinement le nombre de familles
demandeuses a triplé qu'on a peu plus de
300 familles qui sont ravitaillés donc
en ce moment on distribue plus de
6 tonnes par semaine voilà donc ça
correspond un peu plus de 1200 personnes
qui bénéficient de cette aide de colis
alimentaires donc très concrètement
entre les produits secs que nous
distribuons plus les produits frais que
nous récupérons auprès de nos
partenaires de la grande distribution
chaque famille bénéficient d'un colis
hebdomadaires à peu près d'une valeur de
50 euros
donc ce qui fait à peu près que janot
injectant dans le budget des ménages à
peu près de 100 euros par mois pour les
maraudes les repas chauds sont cuisinés
sur place dans les cuisines de
l'association les colis alimentaires
sont pesées préparer avant d'être
distribués aux familles les 50 bénévoles
se relaient toute la journée pour
travailler 7 jours sur 7 comme philippe
qui a rejoint l'équipe au début du
confinement au début de ma mission
j'étais surtout affecté à la collecte
dans les magasins et puis
progressivement j'ai un petit peu touché
à toutes les tâches de la delà de
l'association je peux aussi de la
maraude le samedi soir aussi
10 pas de charge de marchandises aussi
de la préparation de colis avec des
fiches à remplir manuellement ce qui est
très long pour le président de la
mosquée une crainte persiste les
grossissements peu à peu de provisions
et les deux nations se font de plus en
plus rares par exemple la banque
alimentaire
tout ce qui est les deux cartons
alimentaires donc on commence plus tôt
arrivé à la fin de leur réserve la
semaine dernière pour vous dire
qu'habituellement on était approvisionné
quatre cinq palettes la semaine dernière
on en a eu qu'une beaucoup on essaie de
faire des appels aux dons pour qu'on
puisse compenser par l'achat auprès de
grossistes de ces quantités qui vont
manquer les jours et les semaines à
venir
l'association basée sur mantes la ville
oeuvre dans un rayon allant jusqu aux
mureaux même si la demande est plus
forte pendant la crise sanitaire le
centre d'études et d'initiatives
musulmane des yvelines continuera ses
opérations